game tonight president biden is pushing
for gun control a change in the senate
filibuster and better relations with
china and north korea
in the president's words he wants to
change the paradigm
and will do what he needs to quote get
things done
he says he expects to run for
re-election in 2024
what he is not doing following his first
formal news conference since taking
office
is taking responsibility for the crisis
at the southern border
we have complete coverage of his first
solo q a session with reporters but we
start off with
white house correspondent peter ducey
was in the room good evening peter
good evening brett there were 30 of us
socially distanced in the east room the
president spoke for about an hour and 10
minutes he called on
10 reporters whose names were on a list
that fox was not on
folks i'm going before he did he spoke
generally about the growing number of
migrants at the border including 11
900 children in federal custody
insisting
they're not coming because of his
policies i'd like to think it's because
i'm a nice guy but it's not
he outlined one possible solution to
stop the surge we're trying to work out
now with mexico their
willingness to take more of those
families back and says he is aware
some migrant processing facilities are
way beyond capacity
is that's a serious question right is it
acceptable to me come on
now 21 republican senators have written
biden quote your administration is not
only being dishonest about the situation
but actively misleading the american
people and blocking
access to transparency i will commit to
transparency
and as soon as i am in a position to be
able to implement what we're doing
right now just to be clear how soon will
that be mr president
i don't know the president is promising
gun control reform in due time
successful presidents better than me
have been successful in large part
because they know how to time what
they're doing
order it and if his progressive agenda
stalls in the 50-50 senate he is
signaling a willingness to support a
major change in the senate rules
requiring any lawmaker intending to
filibuster to stand at the mic
the whole time it used to be you had to
stand there
and talk and talk and talk and talk
until you collapsed
and guess what people got tired of
talking and tired of collapsing
filibusters broke down and were able to
break the filibuster get a corman vote
so i strongly support moving in that
direction
some of the president's sharpest words
were about state-level republican
efforts to regulate voting hours and
accommodations
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is it's sick
and the president's suggestion is that
no filibuster means easier passage of
h.r one
now before the senate republicans charge
the is about stripping
voter i.d and making d.c a state giving
democrats a permanent advantage in
congress
but biden insists it's all about
stopping republicans from cutting hours
at polling places
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
republicans are apparently not a factor
in biden's calculations about a possible
2024 match up with
former president trump i have no idea
i have no idea if it'll be a republican
party but biden says
he still expects to run for reelection
i'm a great
respecter of fate i've never been able
to plan four and a half three and a half
years ahead for certain
and right before the q a with reporters
the president read from some prepared
remarks where he announced
that his goal now instead of 100 million
cova 19 vaccines in his first 100 days
is 200 million vaccines but despite the
kova 19 talk
off the top no questions in the program
that followed about covet
brett peter thank you for